foreign
let's go to Tulsa Oklahoma and talk to
Julia gulia what's up Julia hello Dr
John thank you so much for taking my
call thank you for calling in what's
happening
well I'm a little nervous but I I think
some of it's because I'm talking to you
but most of it's because
I've been struggling for many many years
about how to make
the right decision for my for my 17 year
old
um and specifically right now the issues
that's come up is that I'm trying to
decide if I should make him go with us
to North Dakota for Christmas or if I
should allow him to stay
in Oklahoma which is with a friend and I
think everything is just
come to this point where I've had so
many years of advice and and
decisiveness
and I'm just exhausted and for whatever
reason this was the icing and I reached
out because I I trust your opinion as a
third party I appreciate that
um yeah
why have you felt indecisive over the
years
I
um
I'm assuming the best guess I have is
that I didn't really grow up with
um a mom or a dad that was really
involved I I had nannies for the most
part and I was the oldest child and I
took care of my siblings as well
um also I so I didn't really have a good
parental role model I put a lot of
thought into this yeah but but also a
lot of the input I've received over the
years the times I thought I was doing
right and really killing it you know
um I've had infants from other people
that they were not in agreement with
what I was doing how I was doing things
so who are these people um and why do
they get
um my husband oh I guess there's that
are y'all still married
um okay so give me an example of a thing
you thought you were killing it and he
was like well you're doing this wrong
well I
I so I had my 17 year old
um I wasn't married and I had him um
right before I was about to go to
medical school
and I postponed medical school for two
years and ended up going through it by
myself with my son okay
um and also through residency
um a lot of that time obviously I was
just in survival mode and
um
you know studying very very early in the
morning so I wouldn't disrupt our free
time together
um obviously there were sacrifices so so
you are you are the top one percent of
one percent of one percent of gangsters
I appreciate that thank you like I can't
think of any reason on planet Earth why
you would be calling me for my my advice
I I you a person I would reach out to
because you not only had the academic
knowledge you've lived it and you
haven't lived it like theoretically or
like had a conversation
you did five to six years of
45 minutes of sleep at night to preserve
a relationship with the little boy and
at the same time learn how to take care
of my little boy when I come stumbling
into the ER in the middle of the night
um right see what I'm saying yeah like
there is there is very few people on the
planet who should be challenging like
well you're doing that one raw and God
bless your husband like he's not on the
phone so I can talk bad about him but
wow I mean wow so yeah so sorry for
interrupting I just I mean I don't get
to talk to just gangsters every day and
you definitely won
that that means a lot to me thank you I
sometimes forget all that I've um all
that I've done I thank you to force with
the trees
um
uh so I because of all of that you know
I really just took a lot of things on
myself like I would just clean the house
right I wouldn't make him take the trash
out I would just get it done because my
time was so limited
and I didn't you know um really teach
him all of those things and hold him
responsible for
for chores and um but he was always
really good at school he was a great kid
always got good remarks from parents and
teachers as far as his character and so
I really didn't focus on that a whole
lot and that's become um a significant
point of contention
now that he's older my husband was
raised totally the opposite
um
um and
I'm and I just don't know how hard to
come down on him as far as
responsibilities and this whole question
about Christmas kind of plays into that
like how hard do I press about making
him do things and and you know do I even
care like even my own opinion of how
important things are is often challenged
I often second guess myself and I also
have to go to extreme to make a decision
what is your what does your husband do
for a living
um right now he stays at home
um he does a lot of
um
gardening woodworking
um Gunsmithing he was a paramedic prior
okay
I
um
I'm just going with my gut on this okay
okay
um I'm pretending that you and I you
came to one of the conferences I was
doing and we you and I are just talking
in the hallway okay okay sounds good um
I studied lawyer mental health and I
studied physician and medical
personnel Mental Health
okay and
there's two tracks that happen
relationally and this is a broad
generalization right this isn't
everybody
right right but I think y'all are in
desperate need you and your husband of
going to marital counseling right now
because things are about to get sideways
I think
all right I think you've got about it's
been a pretty big issue I think you've
well I think there's it's big this is
symptomatic this is into respect issues
and this is into control and dominance
issues
[Applause]
um
okay I don't want to put it all on him
but somebody has made you feel like your
choices and your decisions and your
thoughts about your relationships
are somehow malfunctioning they're not
right
yeah if I don't trust myself that's that
right there
yeah I don't and but that's relational
in nature okay
because something you trusted yourself
enough to go to med school
you judge yourself enough to have this
baby and to figure it out
so at one point you were Unstoppable
and over time you have SL that has
slowly eroded away
I agree it's deteriorated a lot right
and I feel like I'm in a kind of a
bottom point right and generally
speaking again I'm not making you
haven't said this and so I don't want to
speak it into existence but that comes
that erosion comes from
a significant other
slowly chipping away at self-confidence
at what are you doing it well yeah you
clear your doctor but can you can't even
do this and over time it just becomes
this you spin in a Tighter and Tighter
Circle
yes to something as simple as dude
you're coming to Christmas
becomes a paralyzing decision
is it this is ringing a bell right
it's been absolutely paralyzed that's
why I reached out I didn't know what
else to do I mean okay yeah how long
have you been married
um almost six years you all need to go
see somebody like ASAP
okay this is one that you're you have 17
year old you have other kids
yes we have two
they're five and four gosh are you
exhausted and they're awesome are you
exhausted I'm exhausted I'm exhausted
but I have a great life I mean but I am
exhausted
I am spent Dr John yeah I'm exhausted
um here's how here's how I know that
because you could
diagnose me with a I could be having a
heart attack right now and you could let
me know that
but when it comes to relational
decisions in your life
there's there's a block there's a pause
and here's what I would think say about
your kid
um number one I wouldn't blame him for a
second for not wanting to go to
North Dakota whatever crap does he have
something does he have like is he in
love with somebody
yes he just got a brand new girlfriend
of course so it's it's he's gonna just
want to be with girlfriend and I just
want to stay home dude he's he's exact
he's every 17 year old the planet
which is why 17 year olds have parents
and and why we as a society we all got
our heads in we can't just we can't
decide whether something's an illness or
not we can't decide whether to do
chemotherapy or essential oils we can't
decide crap but we've all decided you
know what let's don't let them buy uh
cigarettes or lottery tickets till
they're 18. are we good with that and
then we're like hey you know what let's
just go ahead and pump the brakes a
little more let's not let them buy guns
or or beer until 21 are we all good with
that everyone's like yeah for sure right
we've all agreed on that and so that's
right I say this with all due respect
your 17 year old doesn't get a vote
right he does get input and I'll explain
what I mean by that but he doesn't get a
vote
so the two questions I'll ask you is
question number one is
are you using him as a fantasy to prop
up some sort of Christmas picture you
have
oh no this is actually not I don't want
to go either but I'm doing it so is he
is
so are you going to hang out with your
ex with your ex or his dad his
biological father
oh it's actually my head I had parents
and their family they're very sweet and
kind I just don't like
like Santa coming to our house you know
and not someone else's house but they're
the oldest grandparents that we have and
I feel like it's important we don't get
to see them very often so I feel like
it's important if we have a chance to go
okay I feel like that's ultimately a
priority so so number one your kid is
going to absorb every
every every I'm trying to think of the
right way every PSI every square inch
that you don't want to go
like Vibe yes every every energetic wave
you put into the universe okay okay also
going to absorb all the relational
tension between you and your husband
right now
yes I've noticed that our little kids do
too when there are issues yeah and
unless your husband is a miracle worker
there is a distinct difference between
quote unquote his kids and your kid
and your 17 year old absorbs that too
right and then you tell me I've got to
go to freaking North Dakota in December
and my girlfriend is here and you know
what she wants to do just make out all
of Christmas but no mom's got a dress so
yeah I mean all that is there and so
here's when I say he doesn't get a vote
he's going okay and and I'm just here's
what I'm telling you I'm just telling
you what I would do if it was my kid
okay
but
I'll just say exactly what just happened
I made my 12 year old he's not 17 but
he's almost 13. he had to come with us
um on a on a Texas trip
to see family and I built in a half day
we had a long hunt with an old old
friend of mine a former roommate of mine
a guy that I owe almost all my life to
um I hadn't seen him in a while and so
we went out and did some fun stuff my
father-in-law took us fishing one
afternoon and one day I just kicked a
soccer ball with him forever
right so I built in time like hey while
we're here give me a couple of things
that you want to make sure you do and I
was intentional about planning some
things that I knew he would love and we
made some memories on this past trip
that he'll he'll he'll tell a couple of
these stories at my funeral
right
right I love that there's a he's really
into nutrition right now and working out
yes we're members of the YMCA there's
one where we're going I should call
ahead of time and just maybe set up like
a some time where we can go work out and
do those kinds of things if you said hey
every morning we're doing the workouts
but I want you to design them
uh and I'll do whatever work out you you
challenge your mom bring it bring it oh
no right okay I can do that yeah but
give him some like and then hey pick you
and I are gonna go on a date we're gonna
have to get away from this madness at
some point so you and I are going on a
date I want to know where you want to go
okay yeah and does that make sense it
absolutely does okay yeah so simple but
you know things you don't think of well
here's the thing it's it's
um when it comes to the the
responsibility side
the I I want to look at those as skills
okay and you clearly gave him some great
character skills you gave him some great
he will live with that work ethic your
work ethic is very similar to my mom's
and I
um I'm a result of that I can outwork
anybody because my mom laid a path for
me and I can never say the words I can't
because I I watched that's right my
gangster mom my family is hopefully she
my mom's just let us know she's teaching
at Oxford and she's 72 this summer like
so she laid a foundation for us it's
like there is no excuses at 71 I can't
be like I'm tired I wanna no grandma was
flying across the world to go teach it
so you you've given your son that same
thing here's what you didn't give him
um hey you know how good it feels when
you climb into a maid bed that begins at
6 45 in the morning when you get up so
it's just it's a set of skills and when
new dad goes to war and calls him lazy
or just not being a man or not character
that's dumb because he's going to war
over false pretenses your son does need
to learn some skills and by the way at
17
who got a whole new family at age 11
right yes I'd pick my battles
I'd pick my battles I remember going to
college and my mom over Christmas saying
hey uh how often do you wash your sheets
and I remember thinking
that never occurred to me it never even
entered my mind
right and right then all of a sudden I
had roommates and friends who taught me
about hygiene and then I got married and
then I'm my life is turned out fine
see what I'm saying like it's don't
major in the miners is what I'm saying
you've got a great kid sounds like he
knows how to work hard
um and he loves his mom and he's gonna
put in the time and the effort
um I would
I would re-engage with husband about how
he talks to you about how dumb you are
and how you don't know what you're
talking about
it bothers me Julia it just does
tell me if I'm wrong
no I feel like
still tired
um and after I'm starting to question
other parts of my life too well how can
I be possible will be doing this right
yes career yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes
yeah and maybe that comes from other
places but in my experience it it's
usually rather singular in origin
okay
and I can re-engage yeah well I think
re-engage but I think
here's the way I would approach it
I want a home that when I get done being
a doctor
I can't wait to come home and here's
what that looks like
and by the way
I'm not stupid
and so we're not gonna engage in my
inside my house
in a way that I don't allow my
colleagues to talk to me at the office
I'm not dumb
we may disagree may have different
pictures of what we want things to look
like but you're not gonna call me stupid
you're not going to send me into another
room wondering if I'm insane
because I'm not
you see what I'm saying yeah yeah I feel
like bounced like ideas Just Bounce
inside my head like a ping pong you know
they just I just can't figure out what's
what's right and what's not yes it just
feels like the gas lights are burning
bright my sister and that at some point
if you take on a great gas lighter in
that way it just ends up in big
loop-de-loops the easier way to go about
it is to say here's the life I'm looking
for
and here's the life I want to build
together with you and here's what I need
that to look like and if you're going to
stay at home and be a stay-at-home
whoever great that's awesome here's what
I need
and you haven't asked that question in a
long long time have you
probably not that way no not said this
is what I want it to look like this is
what I need as far as that goes
um do you think how much input should he
have with with discipline I mean he's 17
and so I feel like
I'm just kind of barely hanging on until
he goes to college and really trying to
focus on relationship I don't really
know I mean
what kind of what what does he need
disciplining for
he thinks I need to withhold
allowance and withhold access to a car
and take away his phone things like that
for not doing chores not doing what he's
supposed to do or not doing the chores
the right way
um
I'm just happy to see him when he gets
home he has such a he can have a hectic
schedule and
um
he's making good grades you know he goes
to kind of an intense school I just
I don't know how much input
responsibility to give him on that side
I don't know discipline's important here
here's what that's a whole this is a
whole other call and I'd love to walk
through it with you definitely some
strong opinions but let me let me tell
you this
okay
for some for some reason and I'd love
for you to sit down with a counselor and
walk through this right you no longer
trust your gut
no I don't and you should
okay because you're worth trusting
okay and
yes he should have accountability and
yes he there should be consequences and
discipline all those things are
important
and
um
he's gonna step back and rightfully so
say Mom what do you want from me
I got straight A's
I'm in a really hard high school is he
working
he just got his first job he starts
today and he was doing um football and
wrestling so he was really busy oh so he
is a gangster of discipline right
um uh he's very very disciplined he's
very hard working he's understands what
competition and uh doing the right thing
looks like and doing the hard thing
looks like he knows how to get hit in
the mouth and get back up he knows all
these things he's got a job he's got a
girlfriend
okay dude he didn't pick up his laundry
are we gonna go to war over that right
now right right and so
I like on a lot of those issues the
social consequences he's gonna have
friends and be like dude you smell like
a dead animal or his sweet new
girlfriend's gonna lean over and be like
wow you know what you could have done
this week bathe that would have been
awesome right and there's just some
natural consequences to this
unless there is two Alphas in a
household trying to see who can pee up a
tree the highest right and that it gets
obnoxious
yes I agree you see what I'm saying yes
and God help him dude if if not making
his bed is gonna
my God his life will I learned when I
got married I love my life is better
when I get into a made bed in the
evening it's worth the 30 seconds when I
wake up and in fact it makes my whole
day better
I I I seem to do just fine I did just
fine
I'd much rather see him get to wrestling
practice on time and really do well
there and do well at work and do well as
a person of character and integrity he
tells the truth and he respects his mom
uh mom here's what I want to see you do
I want to see you start to take him on a
date once a week if you can at all
manage it
leave your husband with the other two
and take him on a date once a week y'all
go to some crummy Diner in your town and
y'all go hang out and just be together
talk about the future talk about the
things you've done wrong talk about the
funny stories about your life he doesn't
even know about the time you went out
and you you know you tried some stuff
that concert you went to that went to I
want to start talking about it because
you got about 18 months and he's on his
own he's out of here if that
don't let things unsaid
but this is all about relationship and
your initial question if he's my 17 year
old he's coming with us but he's going
to have some input on what that trip
looks like
and man I am going to lead the way with
a positive attitude with laughter and
when I get frustrated I'm gonna speak it
out hey guys I'm frustrated not at y'all
I'm choosing to be frustrated over the
travel situations or the fact that it's
50 below or whatever it's going to be
wherever we're in North Dakota all those
things
lead the way and you and your husband
y'all need to go talk to somebody ASAP